What?
Cameraman: We're live!
Cordon: Welcome to another exciting episode of The Wokking Dead.
I'm your host, Cordon Gruesome.
But only for today, because I've been fired.
Our new host couldn't start until next week, so this is my last show.
Today's episode is brought to you by Culinart Productions,
putting the crap in craft services.
Dave: I heard that.
Cordon: Oh yeah! Well I heard your wife left you for a baboon at the zoo!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!
THE WOKKING DEAD!!!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!!!!!!!
On today's episode of The Wokking Dead,
We'll be taking a request from a user named BryceMakesFilms.
He writes:
"Hey Cordon. I'm turning 21 next year.
Have any recipes for drinks I should try?"
Well Bryce, lucky for you, I've got just the thing.
First, start by preheating the over...
Heh! Over...
THE OVEN.
To 500°.
Dave: Hold on Cordon. What do you need the oven for?
Cordon: Get in there!
Dave: Security please!
Cordon: Oh! AGGGHHHH--
And here's what you'll need.
Schnapps.
Irish Cream.
And grenaldyine.
Dave: It's Grenadine.
Cordon: Grenadine.
And since I really needed this job, Arsenic.
Cordon: What the? Give me that.
DAGHHH--
And the first thing for you to do,
is to open the bottle schnapps
like this.
*burp*
And if you run out,
you can just get more,
and put it on the company card.
Dave: Give me that!
Cordon: No!
Cordon: You're a dick Dave!
Put EXACTLY one ounce
Into the glass.
I forgot.
*ringtone*
Oh, this is important.
Hold on a second.
Hello?
And then I said,
you can forget about your Grandma's orange juice,
because I'm not coming back.
And then I slammed the door.
Dave: Cordon!
Cordon: Can't you see that I'm on the phone?
Dave: Just finish the show already.
Cordon: I'll call you back.
Where was I?
Oh yeah. Irish Cream.
You put in 1 z-spoon.
Cordon: Bethany you bitch!
We could have been on top of the world together.
*burp*
Dave: Here we go again...
Cordon: But you had to go off with the querulous surfer boy with the timeless bagel...
Dave: What does that even mean?
Cordon: I'll show her. I'll show all of you!
Just wait...
Cordon: Why are all the clouds purple?
Dave: We are inside Cordon!
So finally...
the last ingredient,
is 1/2 z-spoon of Geraldine.
Dave: You're telling me we only had to pour three ingredients into a cup?
Cordon: These actually look pretty good!
Dave: Cordon, I think you've had enough, alright?
Why don't you just take us out?
Welcome to another episode of The Wokking Dead.
This week--
Dave: The other one!
Cordon: Thanks for Wokking the watching Dead!
Remember...
suscribe for your own kitchen.
Dave: Well...
Get him out of here!
I'm sorry for Cordon's behaviour,
but join us next time as we introduce a new host.
I hope to see you then!
There's no way we can present this to our viewers. It's completely unprofessional.
CZ: Look. We have to upload an episode every month.
That's what the fans expect.
Dave: The first three... they were pretty disasterous, but there was something there.
This? It's complete anarchy. You can't upload it.
CZ: You are obligated to deliver an episode every month.
Doesn't really matter what's in it.
Nobody'll notice.
Probably.
Dave: Did you even see that abomination?
CZ: I don't know. If you'll excuse me, I have some "business" to attend to...